[Music]
you come out tonight come out tonight
come out tonight Buffalo GS won't you
come out tonight and dance by the Light
of the
moon say Marina what' you wish for when
you threw that Rod oh no Mary you can
tell me no if I told you it wouldn't
come true come on Mary what do you want
do do you want the Moon just just say
the words and I'll throw a lasso around
it and pull it right down I don't
believe in the moon s that's not a bad
idea you swallow it but you don't
believe in the moon
no Mary what on Earth are you talking
about it it's right there it's obvious
you can tell just by looking at it it's
a two-dimensional object well I bet you
think the Earth is a globe no wait a
minute wait just a minute Mary hold on a
two-dimensional now Mary we sent a man
up there on that Moon he went up and
climbed through outer space Oh you don't
really believe that crap do you what
don't don't believe what what in God's
green earth am I hearing Mary you I
think you hit your head in the bushes
over there that's the moon oh look at
all the photos they show us where are
the stars the Shadows are all Now you
listen here Mary all glory is flying
high upon that Moon oh now that's the
biggest lie of all if we had really
planted that flag on the moon it
wouldn't be slapping in the wind well
cuz there're be no wind well that's
because they designed a special flag for
the photo Mary it has a parallel beam
perpendicular to the moon's surface
otherwise a flag would just be just be
hanging there and you don't see the
stars because of the camera exposure
cameras what cameras George did you see
a camera reflecting off of Neil
Armstrong's helmet when he took the
selfie what in holy hell is a
selfie everything was staged to make
make America think we beat the
Russians one giant leave for mankind my
behind hey what are you waiting for why
don't you tell that broad the third law
of thermodynamics remember none of this
is possible without you join the fight
and sign up for mug club today at louder
withcer docomo club for $89 annually
join the fight at louth cr.com mugclub
today hey before we move on with the
show we are going to have Alex Jones on
this show and go through of course the
new uh recent I should say not new
Colorado ruling this is the last
standard daily live show of the year
tomorrow is the Christmas Extravaganza
special whatever we call it um where uh
Santa does some good around the
community uh so if you just want
something that's you know heartwarming
non-political I often warn you and say
this is a PG-13 just wanted to take this
opportunity to let you know that
tomorrow is absolutely a g program and
it's something you can watch with your
children um and I need to say that
because you're about to see the OG of
canceled comedy Nick depalo standup reel
which is is absolutely uh not rated G
but I wanted to take a moment to thank
you guys here in the spirit of Christmas
Hanukah K Quanza is not real to thank
you mug club uh we launched this year
the re-platforming initiative and
because of you the Nashville Manifesto
happened that is entirely because of you
and the investigative unit we can't do
this without you because of you we
brought on Nick depalo Alex Jones's show
of course that you now get on Fridays
the Hodge twins Brian K and Mr gunsen
gear as a contributor and we are
expanding um and because of you we get
to continue doing this program without
having to serve corporate overlords as
much as I know that sounds like some kid
at Hot Topic who just read Karl marks
look everyone serves a master and in
business you serve a master and uh in
life you serve a master and I think
that's important for us to remember here
around Christmas who are you serving in
your personal life that's an answer that
only you can give and one that you can
choose that's a story of not only
Christmas christ Redeeming the world but
Christmas Carol is like the Fifth Gospel
to me it's about a man redeemed the
Grinch is just another version about a
man redeemed what kind of a god do we
serve if we don't believe that people
can change so if you think you need some
change in your life you can there's
someone in your life who you think won't
change they can pray for them and you
know what right here at mug club we were
uh you know we were in a spot where we
definitely wanted some change and this
year was a year of a lot of change so
Alex Jones the network contributorship
Rumble the
manifesto all of this is because of you
and uh we can't thank you enough and of
course if you sign up you get a copy of
this children's book beautiful
differences that I wrote as a love
letter to my children hopefully it's a
time capsule and it's a love letter to
you guys you get it for free right now
between now and New Year's with any sign
up and that will help determine what we
do uh going going forward including
scripted series other undercover
projects that we are working on none of
it happens without you and I don't say
that as a sales pitch as much as I
really do from the bottom I think of
everyone's heart here as a thank you we
cannot do this without you we never
would be able to consider it a privilege
and it's been uh one hell of a year and
we've enjoyed every minute with this Dam
crew this is going to be a reel of one
of our contributors here of course you
can watch Nick Apollo 5:00 p.m. on
weekdays children should leave the room
see him live while you still can because
he's getting up there in
age give it up for Nick depalo Nicko
Nicko
Nicko Nick
[Music]
Theo the Vince Lombardi rest area that's
the best we can do for the greatest
coach in the history of the NFL a brick
structure up to exit 13A where truckers
who have been living on hooker and beat
jerky for 14 hours can unload their
impacted bowels where gay guys can
exchange filthy jobs at 3:00 a.m. and
where pedophiles can come into the faces
of terrified children you know the
that Vince Lombardi was for you know
Africa's given some good Ebola AIDS L
Sharpton all the things in life that I
love hey a round of applause from the
promly white crowd all right let's see
if they edit that out why nobody's heard
of me after 30 years all the funny
gets cut on the floor to keep a guy from
raping you you should either urinate or
vomit in front of him every girl I in my
20s was puking and pissing herself she
was face how I knew I was going to get
laid you go to the emergency room you
need immediate care what do they make
you do when you get there wait this
nurse comes out with this pissy attitude
how you going to pay for this said uh
with my life if you don't pick up the
pace I'm bleeding like Ted Kennedy's
liver can I get a Band-Aid thank you
people surprised we have a gun problem
how do you think we C the country in the
first place in a slap fight come on what
do we do Noy the Indian for the land
come on sit and Bull Give It Up 50 bucks
Rhode Island come on give it up I'll
burn a hole in your fig Tails thank you
very
much thank you thanks a lot you guys are
one hell of a crowd thank you guys so
much I had a great time I can't thank
you people
[Music]
enough see the funniest man alive Live
May 11th at the count bayy Center for
the Arts in Red Bank New Jersey don't
miss Nick
depalo
[Applause]
[Music]
what I
know
[Music]
strange
see if I were neck too I would go huh
cut sitp for timing sit for timing Sip
and sit for timing uh wow that's a
horrible start he said sip I thought he
said sit my ear doesn't work I went in
too deeply with a Q-tip you ever done
that yeah hey are there any ear doctors
out there comment below one told me that
you are not supposed to use Q-tips at
all ever which doesn't sound
correct I think you should be able to
use them I'm fine with it well yeah but
you're but you're not a doctor all right
bring up the rundown today we are going
to talk about Colorado basically trying
to ban Trump well they have from there
why is it so loud oh because I was doing
Pierce Morgan yesterday so I had to
adapt everything guys let's make sure we
just reset these to 0 Z because this was
set to uh you know pompous red coat
um we talking about Colorado and whether
it is constitutional their arguments we
will have a claim versus truth segment
on that I don't know if you know this uh
migrants are now flying premium to New
York City yeah business class those
miles add up those miles add up they are
Platinum Status we're going to have Alex
Jones as a guest and actually since we
don't have uh the normal program
tomorrow it's going to be chat Wednesday
oh nice which is usually Thursday but
it's chat Wednesday let me ask you this
also what do you think is going through
president Trump's mind right now as this
is
happening I can take a guess but I know
no I'm not ready my vocal cords are not
I'm not going to do it not hor no
no no it's like celebrate good times his
poll numbers are going to go up what you
oh my gosh his poll numbers are going to
go through the roof these folks do not
understand uh the kind of marter that
they are making and this is not
effective we'll talk about that uh and
more here today Alex Jones will be on in
a little minute uh how are you Captain
Morgan I'm doing well how are you man
other than the Q-tip and you know I'm
good I'm good other stuff well no I'm
fine you had dry lips earlier you said I
did have dry lips do you find it when
you get really dry lips when it's the
the weather changes it's hard to talk
cuz you're kind of doing like
that why do you have to do that for do
comments and in third
chair when you hear this it me means you
love him you thank him for his service
first off Friday March 1st he's going to
be at the Funny Bone in De Mo Iowa o so
what else are you going to do Josh firin
how are you sir I'm good and for the
record I love Iowa come see me it's the
best I've never been it's going to be so
much fun how you know it's best you're
in for a treat my friend I knew a lady
who went to college there once and we're
not friends but um she said nice things
about it yeah no I I spent uh I spent a
week in bondorf overnight bondorf yeah I
bet you won't do it again come on now
sorry hey you said you spent a week in
borf overnight yeah I was skimming over
it but you're ruining it also you have a
stroke May 11th no I that was on purpose
I know I'm
kidding because before the show I told
Cat Morgan I said I'm very tired today
so if I missp speake my rule to like
just make fun of me or if I say
something that's incorrect please just
make fun of me that way they can
admonish me so that people don't think
that I'm losing my f I'm running on a
couple of hours sleep that's true and we
have the
office oh jeez that does it somebody
just pulled their car into
a I hope those knocked the tears out of
your eyesu we were about that we're
doing a year in review he was like I was
like are you crying it's been a good
year man I've been taking caffeine
supplements and that's way better way
better by the way I have some smelling
salts if you need them also May 11th
count bisy Center for the Arts you get
to go see the OG of canceled comedy Nick
doollo in Red Bank New Jersey cannot
recommend it I don't know how much
longer he's going to tour right he
really likes doing this show and his
show and he's been doing it for what 30
40 years um look it's he he's the
funniest an of comic alive in my opinion
also uh because many of you will feel
this way at his show live uh on our show
here today is going to get a little bit
rough so if at any point you
see head on over to rumble
okay yesterday before I move on uh I sat
down and I want to say actually I sat
down and I really did enjoy it yeah you
know I don't like doing segments I don't
like sitting down on other people's
shows because it's all just gotcha in a
quadrant view I'd rather take my chances
sit down in a barber shop with 10 black
guys who I know disagree with me because
they have no reason to be dishonest and
I have no incentive to be dishonest
whether it's a change my mind whether
it's talking with people whether it's a
conversation with a professor um so I
was apprehensive you know I don't tend
to do a lot of press but Pierce Morgan
invited me on and I will say it ended up
being a pretty productive discussion I
appreciated it uh we were talking about
Free Speech Alex Jones you can go and
watch the the whole thing on his channel
but here's a brief look he knew the
massacre had
happened what let's listen to what he
said incorrect why do you hate
it I hate it because I don't like Jeremy
Corbin but I I think he's a bombastic
prick but I also think that you should
have let him finish speaking why because
then he would Express bad ideas that's
why I support freedom but you think
socker is
gay homosexual
yes you know what that's a whole another
debate stepen Crowder let's have a
debate about whether sock is gay and if
it is by the way I would be happy to
embrace its homosexual side U well I
know you
would and to be CLE it was in good fun I
was it was yeah you are messing around I
was worried about cheap shots yeah you
know because it's fine if people do it I
just it's not so much that you're
worried about someone taking a cheap
shot on you it's that you're worried
that it's not going to be a conversation
that benefits anyone you've heard me say
I want to get out of this want to get
all of us out of this Rhythm out of this
rhythm of chasing just a Twitter
headline or clickbait or someone gets
destroyed and actually have real
conversations it's good that we're
talking but are we talking in the right
way now he did not take I would argue I
think he was relatively Fair some people
thought that he took a cheap shot with
the David Duke thing I understand what
he was do it I'm appreciative having
done a lot of these interviews in the
past over a thousand I appreciate the
way it went and I uh in preparing this
is something you should know some inside
baseball I went over with Ginger Snap I
said look we a segment and joshh was in
here and you checking out your thread
count
no I'm sorry distract you I think I I
think I got like a powder from a dnut on
me or
something um I I sat that with Ginger
Snap and said look he's going to bring
me on he has this tendency or these
reporters will have this tendency or
journalist to just try and bring up some
random tweet or if I've ever said
anything offensive I said I don't I said
have I said anything particularly bad
about about Pierce and he said no not
that I can think of and
then I watched the one episode in
question and went o I'm not saying it's
right it's not right for example it's
not right for you to be a total prick
but you have it's not right for you to
do it but you have the right you have
the right to be a jint boy but it
doesn't mean right that can be is it
right and do you have the right you have
the right to be a bloated piss
bag I doesn't make it right but you have
the right look at more of a Mot I look
at both sides right like I see one side
you're a prick on the other side you're
an
but I can see both arguments to
be made get make in the middle like the
buttons are between your suit hanging on
for their life clinging together I can
hear you getting fat you have the right
to be a fat bastard doesn't mean it's
right I guess you missed a few Ginger
Snap uh but In fairness you were you
were being count anular look to be
joking about
it's it's Pierce Morgan interviewing a
Scottish man named count danula who was
who was fined in England almost sent to
prison for his dog lifting his paw which
they saw as a Nazi salute hate speech
being asked about Alex Jones being
allowed on X formerly Twitter which was
purchased by Elon Musk who also posts
dank memes come on on guys if you can't
laugh at that you're missing the point
in Life Is that real that's why he was
arrested that's why he was yeah he was
yeah wow his pug went my my German
Shepherd does high fives I'm GNA get him
to do one and Ste frame there you go
just skip the armband
yeah but I will say this and you know
what click the like button if you went
and you you saw the interview I think
it's Pierce Morgan uncensored as his
show let me know what you thought I will
say this he understands that that was a
joke which I appreciate a lot of people
go you know if he he said well you coold
a blowed piss bag that's that would out
of context uh seem bad so I do
appreciate that even if someone doesn't
think it's funny they have to
acknowledge that it was a joke and he
didn't do that and uh I think that's a
step in the right direction and I would
like to have Pierce Morgan out to the
states yeah yeah take him to a gun range
maybe he can take me to a soccer game
you know little bit uh little little bit
of Odd Couple action going to be a
little gay he'll show up like aant hunt
and Tweed yeah where are the hounds I'm
just happy Pierce Morgan got you to uh
defend American football yes I know I
know he did well he said they don't wear
helmets It's like because you can't
touch each
other I mean in the locker room by the
way tomorrow come on or the shower
tomorrow is the Christmas uh program
it's the annual lot with Crowder
Christmas special do you have that
bringing up to man it's the Crowder
gives back I guess is what it's called I
guess well anyways it's where we just do
some stuff for familes charity we work
with some veterans Charities and there
was not a dry eye in the house so we
have to pre-tape that because we
actually went out and delivered some
pretty significant gifts to some people
in need and it's uh it's all part of you
mug Club you guys make it happen hey
before we move on uh it's time for uh
well I don't know if you know this they
brought on a guy named Marshall Cohen on
CNN to talk about Trump and this brings
us to uh CNN's weird face of the
[Music]
day all right bring him
up uh oh what is that goly he looks like
he's in the wrong tribe at at
Hogwarts it's the ghost of Andy Dick yes
it is with
[Music]
bubbles
well yeah there was something better
than that that's been Cen in's weird
face of the
[Music]
day I I love the fact that we actually
have that Stinger a thing it's like it's
like they hired their contributors from
Jim Henson's Creature Shop oh human bar
of soap
Yes
it's you know forunate and by the way
I'm sure he's a nice nice guy for sure
it could be a fish I I have no idea yeah
[Laughter]
well he have a stigmatism he goes in the
autometer says give me give me the
kaleidoscopes yeah I'm a little far away
he just got out of the tanning salon
actually did he actually seen him
yesterday wow yikes
clear it was like one of those fish in
the ocean where there's no pigment
they're just completely
transparent it's weird I'm far more
scared of the deep ocean than I am of
space all right let's talk about
Colorado no not weed so we often hear at
the show you know we rip on dictators
like like xingping or you just had uh
you know Maduro um uh he just persecuted
some political opponents um looks though
like the United
States do we have a leg to stand on with
this when you see what we're doing are
we becoming a Banana Republic genuinely
comment below I I I am concerned when I
see this now I'm not necessarily
concerned about the Fallout because I
think I know how this likely ends I'm
concerned about the actions that are
being taken so Tuesday night and we are
going to uh present to you a a claim
truth segment all references available
lth credit.com why none of this makes
sense none of the left's arguments hold
water and if you disagree with me I
would be happy to read your comments
below and by that I mean have someone
here read
them Tuesday Tuesday night the Colorado
Supreme Court uh 4 to3 ruled that
President Donald Trump some people say
former president some people say sitting
presid I say sitting president okay they
ruled that is disqualified from being on
the state's
2024 GOP ballot the Colorado Supreme
Court um ruling that Donald Trump has
now been
disqualified from being on the primary
ballot for the GOP again this breaking
news out of Colorado Donald Trump as we
know um is now was fighting to be able
to be on that primary ballot the uh
Colorado Supreme Court now issuing a 200
something page opinion that we just got
yes he was fighting he was to toiled and
struggled with a 35-point lead oh
Colorado took 200 pages to write it I
know it's an opinion too by the way yeah
and to be clear let me just kind of give
you a summary of their arguments then
dissect them Point by point they're
trying to say that Donald Trump
committed an Insurrection which we know
is not true they're trying to say that
states can decide if a candidate is
eligible for federal office that is also
not true they're also trying to say that
the uh the well presidents or potential
presidents of the United States are
subject to the insurrection Clause of
the 14th Amendment Section 3 14th
Amendment um none of it actually makes
sense and this is how you definitely
this is why I think he's also gaining so
much ground with black Americans they
believe that the judicial system has
been weaponized against them right and I
will say that there is truth to that I
just don't necessarily believe that it's
racial I think it has been in the past I
think today the concern of the
weaponized judicial system is far more
about class and really not just class
wealthy and poor I mean Elites in power
because you have people who are Elites
in
who make far less than some other people
who they prosecute who they persecute
and that's just because of your
political affiliation or if you happen
to speak against the ruling class now of
course not to be um outdone as as
quizzing or lackeys for the left uh the
elite the the left of course they were
ready to gloat we had a whole show
planned my friend uh and that is
completely upended this is what we're
talking about now I am in front of
festooned with papers in front of me
there are there are very few sort of um
you know magic spells that you cast that
um make make a complex and difficult
problem go away I was thrilled and proud
to be uh in America the opinion by the
the Colorado Supreme Court is that guy
doing something below the camera that we
shouldn't be seeing judicial opinion
very pleased that the rule of law uh was
Vindicated by the Colorado Supreme Court
in this way it's a Cavalcade of weird
faces and I say this as someone look I'm
No George Clooney but those are weird
yeah that guy's nose was really
distracting from any point he was making
and he had like reverse bags under his
eyes oh I didn't notice that I don't
know how that go back go just just show
us still it's like it's the reverse yeah
look at this it's reverse eye bags oh
yeah they come out they're on top and
bottom I don't know how that works ah he
looks like a cartoon bad guy without the
mustach I can't remember which guy it is
that's the last time you'll try an
Insurrection on my watch Donald Trump
yes that's the the guy I'm thinking
of so let's go through the claims that
they are making um but first let me ask
you why do you think you the why matters
why are they trying so hard to get
Donald Trump out of the primary they
always said he was the easiest guy to
beat if that's the case you should want
remember the conspiracy theory they want
Trump to be on the ticket so they can
beat him right they're rigging the polls
I I don't think it holds water because
they wouldn't be making up trumping up
these charges forgive the pun because I
didn't intend it so here's a claim that
they are making which is unequivocally
false that Donald Trump LED an
Insurrection Colorado the Supreme Court
declaring former president Donald Trump
ineligible for the White House under the
US Constitution's Insurrection clause
and removed him from the state's primary
presidential ballot here's the truth um
and it's so obvious that I had to go
over this with everyone here today said
like I just want to make sure right he
has not been charged with Insurrection
or sedition anywhere so they're saying
that he basically forfeits his right to
be based on a charge that he's never
even been hit with oh much less
convicted of exactly no right to defend
himself right exactly and had the
opportunity to go and say actually
that's wrong and here's the physical
evidence which will show some well
actually you're uh you're not allowed to
uh to run for president because you're a
murderer like
what well we said so said well we know
you weren't convicted you say I was
never charged to Mur when did I when did
I do murder and they say well you we
think you could have
he hasn't been convicted of any
crime he has not been charged with
sedition he has not been charged with
leading an Insurrection by the way the
Sham federal election interference case
doesn't even happen until March just to
be clear yeah it doesn't include that
charge he specifically left that charge
out yes when you say he well Smith Mr
Smith because he knew he couldn't
convict of that or there's no chance of
no K roosev running into battle a horse
with a flag in his hand like yes and
this is why this is how you know there's
the court of public opinion and
unfortunately the courts can be used
specifically to manipulate the court of
public opinion now you don't you think
that you think that judges you think
that lawyers you think prosecutors don't
know that it would be relevant that he
has not been Char of course they know
that that's why they want to get this
out so that people like Joy Reed Rachel
mattow whoever is in the newest online
podcast will par it the point and
because of the Insurrection Clause so
people assume they fill in that Gap and
go well I guess Donald Trump must have
committed an Insurrection never happened
hasn't been charged with it the Colorado
court has used Donald Trump's January
6th speech as really the justification
for its decision it says uh in his
speech which began around noon president
Trump persisted in rejecting the
election results telling his supporters
that quote we won in a landslide and we
will never concede he urged his
supporters to confront his egregious uh
to confront this egregious assault on
our democracy to walk down to the
capital ellipses show strength and that
if they did not fight like hell they
would not have a country anymore isn't
it interesting that he they say walk
down the capital yeah and then ah then
something yada yada yada show strength
well let me tell you yada yada y here's
the part they conveniently left out from
president Trump's speech I know that
everyone here will soon be marching over
to the capol building to peacefully and
patriotic Ally make your voices heard
today we will see whether Republicans
stand strong for
integrity of our elections and that is
from that exact speech Just to be clear
but just to provide some more context
all reference available lth credit.com
Link in the description if you think
we're just pulling one sound bite out of
context here's some more examples we
have to have peace we have to have Law
and Order we have to respect our great
people in Law and Order My focus now
turns to ensuring a smooth orderly and
seamless transition of power this moment
calls for healing and
Reconciliation I said peacefully and
patriotically be peaceful be
patriotic it's it's the day after it's
the day of like like this is him the
only reason that this became an issue is
because of the media and because of a
lower Court ruling which basically was
being appealed to the Supreme Court of
Colorado and the lower court screwed up
in saying that he did engage in
Direction and that's one of the things
they're trying to base this off of and
it's like again not charged with it
there even in the lower court and they
can't adjudicate that anyway they want
you to believe that after that clip he
goes I had my fingers
crossed no Tex his Backes H oxy free all
the words what is he the guy carrying
The three-foot Gallows that were
intended for Mike Pence like is he under
there like all right keep going guys by
the way that was the only weapon they
brought right exactly the only weapon
they brought was a Gallows for a they
got from sorry zero weapons only only a
couple people died from the actual riots
the actual riers and then a couple
police only one person conveniently kill
themselves as uh Democratic
inconveniences do yeah yeah it happens a
lot and I mean you know I just say don't
get close to the clintons but I don't
know I can't prove that here's another
claim they killed people
now that's the truth murdered a guy
clinty murdered a
guy uh they are claiming and by they I
mean the left and the media they're
trying to claim that a state Court can
decide that President Trump committed
Federal Insurrection Colorado law allows
for these challenges to occur very
quickly we had a you know tried to case
argued an appeal uh we of course know
that the Supreme Court is a likely
destination um for this decision and
we're ready to present our arguments and
optimistic about uh their review of the
Colorado Court's careful and thoughtful
approach to both the facts and the law
here okay true
Mr uh Bizarro World Hugh Grant
that makes zero
sense not at all so let me provide some
context here let's keep this in mind
right CH you know this well the 14th
Amendment it's part of the um it's part
of the Reconstruction amendments okay
this was designed to Bar former
Confederate officials from holding
office you know those former Confederate
officials who literally took up arms and
tried to kill everybody they disagreed
with in the north to take power also
known as an insurrection I don't know
that any of those guys those Confederate
officials gave a speech and said guys
peacefully go to Washington we want
slaves we want all the slaves go what
they didn't do they didn't do that they
picked up rifles and formed militias and
an army and had a new capital and a new
president put in place you mispronounced
Democrats ah yes my apologies so the
idea that um Section 3 the 14th
Amendment is just for each state and I
say this as someone who believes in
states rights just to be clear in this
case it's it's it's nonsense that they
have the right to decide this would
basically mean that okay let me give you
an example because it was meant to Bar
former Confederates okay it would mean
that former Confederate states could
have simply loaded their ballots with
slave Traders yeah think about that
that's what they could have done no this
is a national election that's where it's
appropriate where there has to be some
kind of national federal oversight
because this is the president of the
entire country the uh section three of
the 14th Amendment of course would not
apply here by the way just to give you
some context too as it relates to
slavery like the Emancipation
Proclamation was written in ' 63 uh it
only reached Galveston in ' 65 uh so not
all the slaves were free they didn't
know that they were free but uh that's
only because the uh carrier pigeon was
racist as A lot of people don't
know that that
changed and it was a time traveling
racist
pigeon that's that's dangerous that's
bred from all kinds of different decades
if you don't and this comes down to when
people say I just just take all issues
on an individual basis is hold second if
you don't have a worldview if you don't
have a fundamental understanding for
example of federalism of of state's
rights of the Constitution of what
actually falls under the legitimate
purview of government certainly
electing national office would apply
right a military would apply the federal
government's role really is limited to
keeping us safe from exterior interior
threats ensuring that everyone is
following the law playing by the rules
and side of that keep their whistle in
their pocket this would fall under that
especially when you have Rogue Judicial
Systems acting the way they are and
violating basic fundamental rights here
is actually even a noted anti Trumper
and um he's also a part-time janitor
between the Rocky Bullwinkle cartoons
John Bolton explaining why the Colorado
courts decision makes no sense the idea
that the 50 different state courts can
can decide a question involving the
highest elective office in the executive
branch
Federal Constitution as to what
constitutes an Insurrection against the
federal government uh is is incoherent a
small amount of money here that the
Supreme Court uh if it gets to the
merits of this if it has to uh will
reverse there there's no other logical
way you can uh apply this and and it
would seow chaos in elections as far as
the eye could see what you sorry this is
just it's this guy hates Donald Trump if
there was ever a moment for him to come
out and do a Victory lap this would be
the time and even this guy who hates
Donald Trump is like ah this is stupid
guys you can't do this yeah weic and but
then you have people like Joy Reed and
and Rachel mattow going out and like
yeah this is great I can't believe it
and Jamie yes thank you and Jamie Raskin
is going out and doing the same thing
it's like you have no integrity at all
you don't care about democracy you just
want to win at all costs that's all it
is I say let him do it I mean it's it's
horrible it's going to make him more
popular it is going to make him you
thought Teflon Don was bad oh man how
about how about uh he's immune to armor
piercing bullets St do you have any idea
what you are going to do to Donald Trump
how you are going to build him up when
you do this all it takes is a slight
amount just a a very slight amount of
education for people to understand the
Constitution what is going on here and
they go oh okay I see what's happening
here and how egregious this is from the
court and we'll get down to this in a
minute they stayed their own decision
because they know it's crap yes of it
isn't going to go into effect well this
brings us to another claim here uh that
so claim is that the section three we
kind of touched on it of the 14th
amendment gives the court the right to
remove Trump under section three of the
14th Amendment of the US Constitution
specifically section three says uh no
officers of the country can have engaged
in Insurrection the court essentially
found that Trump engaged in Insurrection
and reversed a lower Court ruling that
presidents are not subject to section 3
of the 14th Amendment saying they are
subject to section 3 of the 14th
Amendment do you think he's swatting
away peckers underneath
me save it for the Senate room save it
for the meeting
room gives me something to look forward
to delayed
gratification so here's the
truth this amendment does not apply to
Donald Trump at all let me actually read
you the text from section three no
person shall be a senator or
representative in Congress or elector of
the president and vice president or hold
any office civil or military under the
United States or under any state who
having previously taken an oath as a
member of Congress or as an officer of
the United States and then it goes on to
say shall have engaged in Insurrection
or Rebellion against the same or given
Aid or Comfort to the enemies thereof so
section three disqualifies officers who
engage in Insurrection again something
with which he has never been
charged and position he never held right
that's another important Point yeah the
lower court in this case actually
defined this right uh they said that
President Trump or at least presidents
in general Sor I do not meet the
definition of Officer this comes from
cout news we'll make the references
available for you says to lump the
presidency in with any other civil or
military office is odd indeed and very
troubling to the court because this was
written by Dickens the drafters of the
section three of the 14th Amendment did
not intend to include the president as
an officer of the United States right
but so that's the lower court read the
rest of what the lower court wrote and I
I mentioned it a minute ago they said
yes he did par participate in
Insurrection right so this court doesn't
like Donald Trump this court found
something that wasn't even really a
question right here that they could
handle and they said yeah this is odd to
say that this would even apply to yeah
but he did the Insurrection right I I
don't understand what the hell is going
on in Colorado please make it simple for
us to understand you're I understand
exactly what cont they're contradicting
their own rulings though true well
that's true yeah they do do with Alex
Jones I was talking with Pierce Morgan
about this where he goes well he was
guilty the the judge declared him guilty
before it went to a trial found and
people try to say well they had a
default because he didn't provide
information no he provided all of his
financials he handed over texts with
Alex Jones what they said was you need
to know this context they said how much
money did you make off of the Sandy Hook
conspiracy 22 minutes over 8,000 hours
of broadcast when the when the suit was
filed 10,000 hours by the time the the
case actually started or the the hearing
the trial actually started H how do you
calculate that and by the way even if
you calculate it it certainly wouldn't
be many multiples more than your entire
business has made throughout its entire
history take the number what was their
profit during that period of time 22
minutes make a percentage they didn't
the judge declared him guilty because he
didn't hand over the financials
specifically and how much money was made
exactly in relation to Sandy Hook that
would be like someone asking me how much
money did you make here how much money
of mug Club went to uh the period of
time that you dedicated to you know
teasing Pierce Morgan I don't
know it's hard to figure out it's more
than I remember probably it's more than
I remember probably I remember most of
the teasing pretty sure if we go back
through the years o um here is actually
even an anti-trump lawyer uh ta cobs
summing up why the court this an
anti-trump lawyer yeah the
court his name's ta cob yeah yeah and he
looks like he looks like he looks like
the photo negative of the rent is too
damn High guy you know the real key
issue in this case is is Trump an
officer in the of the United States in
the context in which that term is used
in article 3 of the 14th amend right and
and in
2010 you know um chief justice Roberts
explained in free
enterprise um that um that people don't
vote for officers the United States
Article 2 officers of the United States
is commonly understood in the
Constitution uh to refer to appointed
officials H and I I understand that it's
hard for you to take someone who looks
that silly seriously and it's kind of
like almost Santa CLA Santa That's
losing his hair I understand the problem
it's like what it's what I'll do
sometimes when I grow my beard out and I
go I'm going to shave it off but in the
interim I'm going to look very stupid
looks like he he's playing Sheriff at
Tombstone yeah later later this
afternoon or something like one of the
Confederates they would have tried to
keep on the ballot
yes General Cobb yes what you say
yes well and maybe research can pull
this up for me really quickly but I
think they even tried to keep Abraham
Lincoln off the ballot research pull it
up for the Confederate here they did I
think in maybe four or five states
something maybe maybe more than that
like this this kind of thing is insane
and look I want I mentioned this just a
second ago but the they actually stayed
their own judgment you've got the the
quote from them right here
these guys know and and listen
challenging it to the Supreme Court
doesn't mean he actually has to be heard
by the Supreme Court he literally all he
has to do is go yeah we're challenging
this and file the paperwork and he's
still on the ballot yeah that's how they
wrote this they gave him till I think
January 4th to be able to actually do
that this is for the court of public
opinion exact they want this story to go
out there as in the court of public
opinion which is also really dumb
because it's only going to strengthen
him so exactly that's what happens next
right case is going to head to the
Supreme Court this is from the ruling
therefore to M the status quo pending
any review by the US Supreme Court we
stay our ruling until January 4th 2024
if review is sought in the Supreme Court
before the state expires January 4th
2024 then the St shall remain in place
the secretary will continue to be
required to include president Trump's
name on the 2024 presidential primary
ballot until the receipt of any order or
mandate from the Supreme Court so let me
just wrap this up for you okay why this
is bogus Trump did not commit an
Insurrection he hasn't been charged with
trying to commit an Insurrection at all
and states cannot decide if someone is
eligible for federal office no matter
what they try and say as it relates to
the section three of the 14th Amendment
then the Insurrection Clause even if
that were the case does not apply to
presidents according to the Colorado's
own writings the Colorado courts own
writings I don't know if it was ruling
or if it was just their opinion it's
hard to tell but either way it sounds
like someone's writing A Tale of Two
Cities here's why they're doing this and
they just keep shooting themselves in
the foot Donald Trump is leading in the
polls and the left is scared shitless
okay now in the RCP average he's at
three points over Biden in this exact
same time uh this time of the year in
2019 Biden was up by 4.4 now keep in
mind this is keeping outlier polls off
the RCP average but the outlier poll is
NBC or ABC Washington Post that had him
up I Believe by 11 and the New York
Times poll that had him up I think by
another eight or nine so they're not
even consistent the RCP average in
including polls because in the past they
haven't always eliminated outliers or
their definitions have changed right now
if the election were held it wouldn't
even be close is all part of the same
message hey you're alone you're isolated
there are more of them than you there
are not yeah and and look this doesn't
even take into account what's about to
come down the pipe from the next polls
that are coming out I mean I yes I can't
imagine how his popularity is soaring
the fundraising that he's doing on this
already the free media that he is
getting 247 right now from this the guy
can just basically just sit there rally
in color we we actually do know um how
they're going to react to Future PS we
gotten our we have a DeLorean here and
we actually do have a future CNN
reaction to uh polls 3 months from now
oh man oh god oh man oh god oh man oh
god oh
man I think it'll be worse than that it
would be it would be oh them yeah oh Z
oh
them they everywhere This Bitter woke
they just wanted to ruin your Christmas
they want to se Division and then blame
you for dividing the country and say
can't we find some common ground not
when you do this not when you do this
they can do it to anybody so don't lose
sleep over this it's not going to stand
and don't let the left gas light you
into believing that somehow you're in
some small Fringe minority because the
polls show that you're not that they are
and their ratings are dying and all
these Shenanigans by the way um may make
you feel like you're in uncertain times
which is why though even though you're
not in uncertain times right now it pays
to be prepared it's a good idea and
that's why um here one of our very few
sponsors last of the year uh with
Patriot Supply we
have what Gerald what happened to the
who in the world would dig into your
Patriot supp I am I am so sorry I owe
you a thousand SAS uh about what
happened SAS this it better not be
another one of your Hanukkah things no
it's not um I kept Mya um in fact you
said you loved my um Mom suf that she
baked for you well it's no gingerbread M
no but you still have some more of them
um just leave them on my desk is there a
reason that you barged in here Sam oh
yes I'm so sorry let me please explain
about what happened it was late on
Friday afternoon and everyone but Gary
and myself went home early Russian gar
you know me knows to the grindstone Gary
was obviously napping under Gerald's
desk we found ourselves in quite the
predicament when the alarm set and the
doors locked wait wait why why didn't
you disarm the alarm I uh forgot the
code but that's not the important part
when Gary woke up we both were quite
peckish and found your bucket of my
Patriot Supply we determined that it was
indeed an emergency so we dug in again
my apologies I kots with Gary and we put
our funds together to buy you a
replacement at prep withth crow.com
okay sorry I'm late alone Stephen what
for the love Russian G we're in we're in
the middle of a show Josh I'm sorry
about this I'm sorry here's your new
bucket of my Patriots okay thank you oh
that was nice well that bces great what
is going on here Russian gear what is
this this past weekend Sam and I had an
amazing conversation and it all started
to make sense my eyes have been opened
to the beauty of the Hebrew language and
the Jewish religion the teaching the
lifestyle a closeness to God one can
only feel as part of the chosen people
and of course the greatest holiday
traditions and Foods The Gila it's
amazing I think you'd be really
interested all right okay thanks here
take a pamphlet no I don't get out just
no get out you to Sam go but I um no you
may not add anything leave Shalom Steven
whatever have a good Hanukkah all right
prep withth cry.com you get to save $60
right now on a 4-we uh emergency food
kit again do you know have to be a
prepper or believe there's going to be
some kind of crap hit the fan scenario
youever been through an earthquake you
ever been through an ice storm just some
dried food you been through an elction
have you been through an election or an
Insurrection just kidding none of us
have take a look at that pamplet yeah
yeah yeah yeah no stop Josh yeah yeah
it's actually just a it's actually just
a good RX coupon
so nice mean you can save me money and
you didn't tell me
fine had to mention the fact that good
RX exists well watch he's going to be
running our banks after he gets through
that goodness oh no by the way I know
that thank you I've been looking for a
reason to not do stuff around the house
on
Saturdays well it's mostly Friday night
to to always ask me to do this and that
and this you say I'm one of the I'm one
of the chosen people over
here look at me yeah not her I won't let
her read this no no no no I I let my
women read no not a gentile like her but
uh prep with.com by the way they sent me
some more oatmeal so it really a great
sponsor and uh they it's the best deal
that you have going on that I know you
can buy other stuff but honestly I
haven't seen a better deal no not just
saying that when was the last time we
did a sponsorship on this show it's been
many many weeks I don't definitely a
couple weeks yeah these people actually
came out remember and spoke in to the
Green Room they were like here we have a
bunch of but they gave me way too much
of the oatmeal and pudding I was like I
appreciate it but like this is way too
much there's well don't wor I took care
of it yeah you
did they don't have do they have mashed
potatoes I don't even know Josh I don't
know we're getting off the beam here
okay fine by the way M Club consider
joining since this is a high
point you get more of let's talk about
this uh the migrants I don't know if you
know this um this week so going back to
Donald Trump let's set this up uh
president Trump told his audience at a
rally that illegals were um poisoning
our country which of course caused
people to lose their minds we got a lot
of work to do they're poisoning the
blood of our country that's what they've
done they poison mental institutions and
prisons all over the world not just in
South America not just the three or four
countries that we think about but all
over the world they're coming into our
country from Africa from Asia all over
the world they're pouring into our
country nobody's even looking at them
they just come in the crime is going to
be tremendous the terrorism is going to
be terrorism is going to be and then we
built a tremendous piece of the
wall tremendous wall he said tremendous
lot there tremendous I think he even
said tremendous terrorism he needed his
the stour tremendous in a bad way though
um so a video just went viral showing a
flight from Phoenix and we're going to
get into some of the context here but
you may have seen this video uh this
there was a flight I believe was from
Phoenix to New York City right um packed
to the brim with uh some unruly illegal
migrants who apparently got all the
premium seats are you tired of paying
too much for flights sick of all those
extra Fe bees from other airlines then
fly spirit that Spirit Airlines would
cut out the extras to save you money our
planes are nice and new too so why pay
more save money and fly in style with
Spirit Airlines book your flight today
at spirit.com
sorry I don't know how that commercial
got in there we run a commercial agency
here um by the way that was rejected
this is the actual clip I'm at the
Phoenix airport right now I'm wai to
board my flight to New York uh to JFK
and it looks like we have a whole lot of
migrants who are also boarding this
flight that the US taxpayers are paying
for this is what the us taxpayers are
paying for right here premium seats on
Delta that they have people coming here
we're paying for this shipping them out
to New York City because guess what
everywhere else is at capacity so they
have these Sanctuary cities like New
York that they're now shipping these
migrants to that we're all paying for so
the lady posted that was Ashley stclair
she tweeted out or xed out whatever she
said when I asked a Delta representative
if this was the case her response was
what does it matter they're humans too
now look before we get into the
information that I think is is is pretty
important here I am not going to say
that this country has been historically
without discrimination that is not lost
on us just to be clear also Hitler bad
we all know that before we get into a
conversation regarding illegal
immigration thank you but we are not
above apologizing recognizing when the
United States was wrong for example I've
had to re-examine some of my favorite
holiday classics through a different
more modern
[Music]
lens
we really should have seen it at the
time it's that was the director's cut
that one's on
us if the WB Bandit saw that they would
been gone yes sure though it's that one
is you know we were maybe toned deaf a
little bit back then gosh I still like
it though we better now
so the investigative journalist uh
Taylor Hansen also um this is a little
while ago revealed how a lot of these
migrants are gaming the well quote
unquote Asylum
system
okay simply for
work just interviewer one of those
racist
whites speak Spanish
yes now just to be clear when people say
Asylum Seekers we have very clear
definitions as to what Asylum is economy
is not one of them economy is not one of
them religious persecution you know if
you have for example a political ruling
class who executes political opponents
and you're supposed to go to the next
nearest country who will take you in to
provide you Asylum and they say no no no
we just want money that is not a reason
for Asylum and certainly not a re
certainly not a reason to give away free
benefits to be clear now let me also
give you some other numbers here that
are relevant before you say these people
are humans too yeah you know who else is
a human the the the mom with screaming
triplets who's just trying to get home
to Pennsylvania for Christmas or some
turkey and homemade pumpkin pie that
person had to pay for the flight this is
where America first comes in it doesn't
mean everybody else laughs it doesn't
mean that we're racist it means no no no
Americans who pay these tax dollars
shouldn't be giving them to people who
are not fleeing persecution but want to
benefit from the social safety nets to
which they have no right let me give you
some other stats these illegal
immigrants they often have no set court
date just to be clear these are Asylum
Seekers Asylum Seekers who you just saw
said they're not seeking Asylum they
said are you seeking Asylum their answer
was
K J I want Dental roughly 40% never
attend their court date
anyway think about that they often have
no set court date if they do 40% don't
attend now let me give you some stats on
the Biden Administration and illegal
immigration um the Biden Administration
has allowed over 200,000 illegal
immigrants to fly into the United States
and be paroled wow and this is a new
number it shocked me this morning
because we gave you the last high water
mark
Tuesday
Tuesday Tuesday now I say that because I
you're thinking also Wednesday
no two days tell me exactly no incorrect
no just this Tuesday the day being
Tuesday Tuesday being the day in
question one day
12,600 illegal Crossings that's the
worst day ever in recorded American
history if you were to average that out
to a daily number it would come to 4.5
million people in a year that's the
population of Louisiana or Kentucky
added every year 125 that's more than
the Portland Trail basers had this week
yes I don't understand the sports
reference small Arenas oh okay I get it
is it is it is it 125 they're like 15 16
but hockey league in Grand Rapids and uh
they got more than that yeah well it's
popular sport yeah that's the kind of
the point think about that sorry I
interrupt you with with such a my brain
short
not I just don't get I don't know
everyone else knows you should admonish
me I just r i just pull a Gerald and
ruined a sports J I don't ruin sports
jokes I ruin other jokes what what what
sport is the Portland Trailblazers it's
basketball n NBA so an arena full of
people came on yesterday in one day
there we go and by the way this affects
you the massive influx of people who
have no business being here and by the
way I would say the same thing if they
were Swedish and white
cause train traffic to be halted from
Mexico the economic group I spoke with
tells me that these two rail closures
are not just going to impact border
cities or larger cities that are seeing
an increase in migrants like Chicago or
New York these two rail closures are
also going to impact the entire country
anywhere that businesses receive goods
from Mexico because those goods are
going uh to take much longer to get to
their destination now hit the like
button
if not only do you want to see Donald
Trump Deport every last one of them on
day one but you will no longer even
entertain the
idea of being shamed into feeling racist
because you think we need to have border
security that's where I am remember what
it used to be hey hold on a second you
know we what do we do with the dreamers
the anchor and so Republicans
capitulated all right those kids didn't
do anything it's not about that when you
have over
12,500 I think 1200 12,600 people in one
day don't talk to me about anchor babies
this is what the left will often do and
you cannot allow them to do they'll do
it for example with abortion let's say
what about rape and incest here's what
you do and people will often say why
would you make those exceptions I'm not
I'm making an argument say okay all
right all right if we allow exceptions
for rape and incest would you ban all
other abortions well no well well then
don't do that then don't try and bring
it up that's not the argument you're
making don't allow them to frame you in
when they say what about what about
babies who were born here you say okay
hold on a second if we allowed babies
who were born here within these very
limited parameters to have a path to
citizenship would you Deport every well
no that would be cruel then don't bring
up the babies who were born here don't
allow yourself to be taken off course
because then they say see you're a
racist see you hate women none of that
is true
12,600 people who have no business being
here are getting free flights sorry
cross the border thousands of them
getting free flights not even attending
their court dates and they're not even
seeking Asylum hold on a second you're a
racist if you say I don't believe that
the people who are coming here for free
how do I know because they say
they're coming here for free
shouldn't be able to take the free
that I pay for with the that I
worked for yeah that's what they do
though they attack your character so
they can delegitimize your opinion or
delegitimize your your your point of
view exactly oh racist okay how about
this here's another solution no more
social safety nets for anyone at all
outside of
disability how about that none then it's
not a problem they want to then you can
have open
borders of course no one wants to do
that no it's a very very different world
when you have more and more th this is
the multipronged approach promise more
free things so let me let me just walk
you through the life here of um someone
taking all the bennies from a leftist
okay come to this country don't attend
your court date all right you get to
work under the table because likely
won't pay taxes okay you never get
deported then maybe you go to school you
have your student loans
forgiven uh Co happens you don't pay
your rent you get that
forgiven every single contributing
member of society who is not on the
social safety net is being screwed along
the way think think about that the
taxpayer all all across that whole
personal Journey as you eat prey love
across the free in this land that
you're not entitled to school well they
lose money don't worry the taxpayers
pick it up medical expenses medical
expenses just walk out of the emergency
room they can't track you don't worry
the taxpayer pick it
up rent no rent forgiveness don't worry
the landlord will lose the property good
news is Vanguard Black Rock will be
ready to buy it up yeah they didn't get
forgiveness and don't worry you'll be
able to vote without ID because IDs are
racist and don't worry the taxpayer will
pick it up think about that you have
migrants they're flying across the
country we don't even know where they're
flying some they're not seeking Asylum
they're mostly grown men nothing is
being done to stop it it's an invasion
this is an invasion I don't I'm not
saying an invasion of brown or of black
it is when people talk about the
replacement Theory okay I know that some
white supremacists have co-opted that
and tried to turn it into a race thing
like I've said I would take 10 patriotic
naturalized citizens from Uganda over
one socialist from Finland okay but
let's be clear about this it's a plan to
replace American taxpayers contributors
who tend to vote overwhelmingly
conservative with people who come here
for free stuff it's buying their votes
it is replacing contributors with
purchased votes that's what the
replacement is it is replacing
contributors with purchased votes Blue
Collar people too conservative
mostly blue that's another thing they
say blue collar those people vote
Democrat no not if they pay taxes not if
they have families that's the thing yeah
that's how you the best isn't it kind of
crazy where people say well as people
get older they tend to become more
conservative well as as people pay taxes
they tend to become more conservative
well as people have children they tend
to become more conservative hold on a
second all of that's why the left has to
paint those things as anything other
than a virtue wait a second we used to
respect and honor our elders in other
words if if we notice a trend where as
people get older they become more
conservative as people have families and
contribute more to society they tend to
develop a worldview and this happens
with every generation once they cross
over maybe there's something there
instead we Pander to people who've done
none of those things or people who
aren't seeking Asylum they just want
free that's the replacement Theory
the replacement is replacing
contributors with purchased votes that's
why the New York Times ran that story
about that whatever beno's Bluey
knockoff is uh with the with they they
they're upset because the father was too
present oh really the father's too
present and takes too much uh interest
in his kids right lives and uh that's
bad for America yeah they should do
another Home Depot commercial where the
dad gets caught in the blinds cuz he
doesn't know what he's doing and there's
a gay voice over the top of it yeah Dad
is this Lumber or steel I have no idea
is it a
softwood pine is a softwood by the way
my desk split one time hey also I know
that you are going to see Josh and Nick
but Brian Kal also a member of mug Club
he's going to be at the comedy zone in
Charlotte North Carolina on December
29th 30th and 31st uh his show of course
off limits is every week on mug Club so
you get a lot of content here on Mud
Club and we're working on some
pretty pretty high level investigations
do we have uh Alex Jones here on the
line I know we're a little bit yeah we
see him is he here all right so you know
what uh I talked about him and uh
hopefully was fair but also defended uh
my friend and what was a respectful
interview yesterday Pierce Morgan uh
let's bring on the show Alex
[Music]
Jones
Mr Jones Mr Jones can you see me
sir yes sir I actually been sitting here
about 30 minutes watching listening to
you guys while I'm get ready for my own
show and I have to say you did a great
job with Piers he actually let you talk
the last time I was on with him he would
just not shut up the entire time and
it's like this Groundhog Day I hardly
ever talked about the school shooting in
Connecticut I wasn't banned off the
internet for it they dredged it up later
with a PR firm promoted it said I did
all these things I never did never sent
anybody to anybody's houses no one ever
peed on Graves none of that ever got
proven I was defaulted by judges in
Connecticut and Texas and now every time
I'm on a show I'm supposed to apologize
even though I apologize for what I did
do six seven years ago just saying okay
maybe I I think it didn't happen but
that's still your first am right so they
misrepresent it and it's like Groundhog
Day where I was on a week and a half ago
with Elon Musk and biic raswan and
everybody else and and they it got kept
being brought up over and over and over
again then more people would join from
the mainstream media on Spaces and say
are you ready to admit it happened and
I'm just sitting here going I I started
saying it happened years before I got
sued I'm not the Sandy hookman so thank
you for explaining that to people uh
Stephen and and I'm sad that anybody
associated with me keeps getting
hammered with that but no no no no don't
be you don't need to be sorry and you
know what one thing though I do want to
clarify for some because some people are
saying you know I really don't
appreciate that stepen threw Alex the
bus where he said he was wrong I said no
no Alex said he was wrong and apologized
he never you never said I lied you said
that I believed something and as more
information came out I was wrong right
I'm I'm not misstating you yeah you
didn't throw me under the bus listen
you're on the year hours a day I'm on
the hours a day I've said it I've been
wrong about a lot of stuff now my
batting average is still you know super
super high I'm like 95% accurate but but
but but but but I say things all the
time covering mainstream media that
turns out to not be completely accurate
but I'm not doing it on purpose I want
to be accurate but I don't just get up
here and say controversial things to get
attention right I I want to have
credibility and and and that's what they
have the saying Alex Jones was right
people know I'm way more right than I'm
wrong and look I mean when Jesse smallet
happened I was already being sued for
questioning an event right and when I
heard 230 in the morning 20 below zero
white dudes with bleach and and a rope
this is MAA country it just didn't sound
real and I said I think this is a fake
event right and it turned out it was
fake and I I I'm still when I think
something's fake fake I'm going to come
out and say I think it's fake now one
chance out of a thousand there were
really white dudes in 20 below at 2:30
in the morning uh throwing bleach on
people and putting noses over them and
saying this is Maga country and then the
police get there and it's a tiny little
rope around his neck it was a shoelace
from P it was a it was a shoelace so I
was right about that and and you know I
thought that there weren't wmds in Iraq
turn out I was right about that and
remember mine Albright said we killed
500,000 children by tripling the
sanctions under Clinton on Iraq not even
letting them ship medicine or food in
she said I'd do it again I'd kill
500,000 they love her I haven't killed
any children though I guess I was
involved in abortion back when I was
dumb didn't know what I was doing so I
actually have killed children but I
haven't killed 500,000 like her and I
didn't do it deliberately and I wouldn't
do it again now that I know uh what I
was doing you know when I was a teenager
paid for some abortions I it's terrible
okay
Alex Alex you don't need to tattle on
yourself on everything it's okay we all
make mist but this brings me to the
point that I was wanting to make with
with pi and I and by the way I do think
that maybe the needle moved a little bit
there um is we also need to live in a
society where it's okay to be wrong if
people can't be wrong ever then guess
what you lose Ingenuity right you lose
creative you lose the ability to take
risks um this is something that isn't
original you know people like Patrice
O'Neal people like Nick depalo uh they
all said that you know good and bad
jokes come from the same place good and
bad ideas often come from the same place
you need to be able to engage in good
and bad ideas and I've seen this not
just with Pierce but I've seen it with
other people in the media what happens
is if you don't apologize or you say I
don't think I was wrong they blame you
and say why don't why aren't you showing
remorse and if you do apologize or let's
say you remove something that you posted
because you believe you were wrong they
say so you took it down you took it down
which means you were wrong right and
they brow beat you and that is a place
that is far scarier to me than simply
allowing people to speak I don't want to
be a culture where people don't have the
ability to be to be wrong everyone's
wrong well the point you make is Central
stagnation happens when you're not
allowed to ask questions or be
controversial Freedom happens when you
are it's why everybody wanted to come to
America because we did have the
strongest free speech in the world for a
very very long time and now an
electronic Berlin wall or Iron Curtain
of censorship is lowering all around the
world look at communist China they're
not allowed to question the party
they're not allowed to criticize their
supervisors they're really not supposed
to come and say when something's wrong a
factory or a laboratory and that's why
it's very well known that China puts out
some of the worst crap on the planet
copies of Western inventions because
they don't just have planned
obsolescence where things breaks they
can sell you new ones they literally
produce crap not because they're not
smart IQ eyes but because they're not
allowed to basically question what their
bosses are doing yeah and you know what
if you go the extreme example is China
right or or some of these actual
communist Nations then you go to a
middle ground before we get to the
United States if we're the extremes and
it's where uh people like Pierce Morgan
are from and I say this because I'm from
Canada you know count danula the fact
that he could even face jail time the
fact that our friend Mike Ward was put
before human rights tribunal in Canada
for a joke the fact that a man was
arrested in the UK for doing a cover of
kung fu fighting at a karaoke bar and a
Chinese actually no a man uh was walking
by the karaoke bar and he wasn't even
Chinese and he was offended so this is
the only place where the First Amendment
exists and I don't think people really
understand how pivotal and Central that
is I know we talk about it a lot but I
really do you just mentioned sort of the
the uh the Iron Curtain kind of coming
down on on social media you know we're
talking about this here where everyone
just might want to hit a clean slate
policy in this new year delete
everything on our social media all of
our old stuff by the way they do that at
the New York Times they do it at the
Washington Post because they want to um
they they don't want to be liable they
don't want culpability but do it so that
everyone can start using social media to
serve us and not serving this algorithm
nonhuman brain I think that a lot of
people feel like they are caught in a
system and don't know how to get out of
it because it's necessary for employment
I think if a enough people just go all
right clear it we're going to use these
tools as they were meant to serve us
it's just a thought because I'm scared
for where we're going that's right not
complying with the algorithm and the AI
censorship is what overrides it what
gives the AI the power is the submitting
to it and acting like it's God VI Ramis
Swani made a great Point uh last week
when he said
as soon as they brought into sports he
named tennis AI even though it was way
at first worse than the humans calling
uh what was happening people stopped
arguing because well it's a machine it
must be better than us and it's the same
thing no it's used programming the AI
and take Elon Musk that's why Rumble is
so important but now the EU is coming
after Elon Musk trying to literally shut
down Twitter Tak it over tens of
millions of dollars of fines because
he's allowing misinformation out and
they Define that as saying the co
vaccine doesn't work which they now
admit it doesn't basically so think
about that folks we need to support R we
need to support what Elon mus is doing
because he's really getting more and
more hardcore I've noticed that just
lately uh you know even you traffic to
you on Twitter is is is going way up
from I've talked to some insiders over
there they say that he really is trying
to make it as open and free as possible
I thought you were saying insiders here
I was like Alex you don't need insiders
at my office just ask me I'll tell you
what you want to know you don't need
moles at Lou her with Crowder just get
stole my lunch off the table last time I
was there I don't need an insid to know
yeah that was Joe Lewis you fed him the
day before what was he gonna do Alex now
I have to now I have to retrain him Alex
is the worst with Joe Lewis he'll I'll
be like Alex you can't feed him like I
just gave him a breakfast sandwich I'm
like that's a whole sandwich
Alex I love that dog I know that dog he
loves you when you come in you can see
his whole body Wiggles he's like oh Alex
uh first stuff I'm going to get
affection I'm going to get pets uh and
then I'm going to get free food so let's
just baby steps on the food because you
see how big he is he can get up on
anything there now at my house on the
high countertop he took a whole pumpkin
pie at Thanksgiving oh my the whole pie
all right well no that produ some
horrible farts yes it did yes it did but
uh Alex I do appreciate you you know
being on and obviously people know they
can watch your show uh here on mug Club
on Fridays I mean what they're doing
with Elon Musk is what they did with
Rumble you know this happened with the
EU this happened with the government of
France first and of course Elon Musk has
a bigger profile than any individual at
Rumble because they don't necessarily
like to be in front of the camera but
they have done this in the past they've
been doing it with Rumble and I really
do hope that there's some not just
[Music]
some
the importance of it but back then you
were still serving your audience right
you weren't blocked from your audience
because someone said no no I want them
to only see content through an algorithm
if someone subscribed to your channel
they saw your content that is and that's
only really three years now that's the
fundamental shift in consumption of
media and that's why people become so
easy to manipulate and I'm not going to
lie I'm I'm terrified of it well here's
a real world example and I'm not a Tech
expert but I read about it in the in the
in the different Tech Pages remember
just 5 years ago or so when you were
driving somewhere in the country didn't
know where you were it would show you
basically every gas station every
restaurant and they were all over the
place and you could pick well now when
you're on Google Maps or whatever it
only like why we just passed three gas
stations why does it say there's one
five miles down the road because those
groups are paying to advertise so they
trained you that oh it lists all the
restaurants all the gas stations all the
museums all of the hotels no it does it
now and it's the same for all of these
things so the censorship isn't just
people's political views it's it's
information about
everything that must be how racetrack
stays in business I'm a quick sh man
damn it I don't want to step at
[Music]
racetrack
links up to the live show uh on X as
well and I should have exed out that I
was coming on with you I'm going to get
better about that most days I forget to
say I'm coming on my own show but it's
really exciting but we have to use this
or lose it we've got to use Rumble we've
got to share Rumble we've got to use x
we've got to share it and thanks for
standing up for me there with Piers
Morgan I wish he'd knock it off I'd come
on his show and have a real discussion
about other issues than the damn Sandy
hook thing no I know it's just it's it's
I I think that there are baby steps
being made and you know what maybe I can
be uh I can be the moderator but I
wouldn't bet on it I think it would be
fun if he we all went to a gun range
together but one of you might shoot each
other so baby steps that would be viral
that would be yes let's invite Pierce
down and and let's uh I guess he lives
in the UK let's do it yeah well then
he'll take us all but then he'll have to
take us all to a soccer game I don't
know I don't know I'm thinking this I'm
thinking out loud but Alex Jones we must
let you go go prepare for your show
Merry Christmas brother we'll talk with
you soon you bye seor that's
[Music]
enough Tim Alex Jones you he cut
you Jim it's almost is your name's not
on the wall well tomorrow is the uh
Crowder gives back Christmas special and
like I uh I told you earlier it is G you
can watch it with your kids we want to
have something that you can just enjoy
wholesome sitb back and and really shut
off because I'll t look let me let you
in a little
secret uh having worked at Fox News and
having having appeared on I don't know
how many times CNN BBC Sky News
HLN
CBC everyone takes it the holidays they
take Christmas off so apparently no news
happens so just to be clear it's like
it's a skeleton crew is what they do so
hey if they're going to take it off then
I would say spend some time with your
family uh focus on the things that
matter and you know what really this
break we do have some decisions that we
all have to make really concentrate on
what it is that you want out of this
next year not I just want to lose some
weight
but how do you want your life to look I
I can't tell you how many people I speak
with who feel like they are caught in a
rat race and a huge component of it is
The Chronic stressors of social media
and the
algorithms that's not the kind of life
you have to live if you don't look at it
it just disappears so we started the
show oh there you are did you hear Alex
Jones talk about you Joe Lewis did Joe
are you where you just walks around for
pets and leaves he heard I think he
heard Alex Jones's voice and he said I'm
going to come in he's not here Josh look
at my butt
oh nice qued Alex is not here Joe it was
a TV come here it was a TV there's no
Alex there's no Alex see that that's why
he's like no I'm leav he came like
there's Alex Jones all right so we
started the show with you watch that uh
that old parody of it's wonderful life
the Flat Earth Edition I don't know how
much we had been drinking when we wrote
that sketch
but what always bugged me about that
film and a lot of people haven't seen
this director's cut it was a lot darker
than you originally anticipated so um
we're gonna show this to you before we
go to mug Club but you remember Mr Gower
and the rat poison in the pills and you
know the drug the drug yeah back then
fun name we thought that he was just
smacking the kid because he messed up
the pills but then he was corrected it
no in the original version turns out Mr
Gower didn't care about the poison he
just liked hitting kids what by that
medicine should have been there an hour
ago be over in 5 minutes
for
what is this blaz voice
capsules didn't you hear what I said yes
what kind of tricks you play
away why you right into the limit room
right away don't you know that boy very
sick he any my s ear you lazy loaf Mr
card you don't know what you're
doing just look and see what you did
look at the botle you took the PO from
it's poison I tell you it's poison
don't do my story it wasn't your fault
Mr
go I know you feel
bad you're shaking the house down stop
it oh let them
alone
[Music]
what
yeah